how many single people does it take Oh
packaging Charlotte oh yeah love is
great Valentine's Day sucks ass I hate
valentines day I can't wait for it to be
over I like chocolate it kind of ends
there all you have to do is look at my
dad cap in my outer shirt to know I'm
spending Valentine's Day alone I think
that suits you so cute
it does suit me that's the problem
people in relationships have much better
places to be than Starbucks on
Valentine's Day
I don't like sugary [ __ ] what's
happening are you drunk no why does
everyone always think I'm drunk what's
the difference between molten and just
normal chocolate you know those cakes
were you like you cut into them and they
just the chocolate how are they gonna do
that a drink
I'd add to love to lack thereof oh it's
so bitter that's not even that bitter
this is sweetest I mean I think life is
bittersweet so why not have your coffee
bitter sweet sweet sickly and think yeah
that's like Valentine's Day no neecy's
calories man just eat a dessert I know
just have like a brownie with your
coffee
how much fun you could get the brownie
in there this one looks chocolatier
already this chocolatier reward value
drink beverages hi that's all you're
single the only thing more Valentine's
Day about is that it's like sweeter and
like I love your sweetie
which like saying that makes me wanna
gag and vomit a single or a couple
you're not going to sit there and just
drink a hot chocolate on Valentine's Day
no one's ever loved me enough to buy me
a hot chocolate or coffee so I love you
enough people are going crazy for this
stuff yeah if you're a basic this hot
chocolates for you
this is the Beyonce of the group for
sure ittsan so single I am right now
like this is so much more attractive to
beat than like okay well why wouldn't
they have like a nice pink icing or some
point no some people are like oh this
looks so delicious I'm like I don't want
a dessert in a cup me either
mmm Michael Tighe sweet head so good no
I don't drink this when I was 12 and now
what does this have to do with this only
now put that in this there you go ha ha
ooh I'm gonna be doing on Valentine site
alone in my bed drinking this all day
long I take everything back if someone
got this for me on Valentine's Day I
would out I'm so good it's better than
taking me to Red Lobster it's hard to
mess up chocolate I'm ready Starbucks to
make a commitment to you the markets
missing an opportunity to target people
who are not in relationships on
Valentine's Day they should be like that
you don't need no man latte yeah I don't
need a Mountie I don't need no man I'm
good you know what I would like a
Starbucks wine
oh I'm iced red wine I had wine out of
Starbucks in the LAX Airport over cousin
Wow why are we doing that taste test
yeah that's one oh so a person can get
right on that's just called getting
drunk in a bar
Oh